the Federal Reserve begins a two-day
meeting today and is expected to raise
interest rates now this comes amid sharp
stock declines that are hammering
Americans 401ks that's not good the Dow
plunged 507 points yesterday all 30 Dow
stocks declined and the S&P 500 dropped
54 points it's down nearly 5% for the
year
CBS News financial contributor Mellody
Hobson is here to explain the market
uncertainty and joins us at the table
hey melody good to see you good morning
so good to have you this it really is
because investors as you know do not
like uncertainty this was the lowest in
14 months so what's the deal well the
market doesn't like uncertainty there
either and this is the story we've got
uncertainty in spades right now so it's
not tomorrow's Federal Reserve meeting
they have widely telegraphed that
they're going to raise rates tomorrow
it's what are they going to do in 2019
that has the market rattled on top of
that we have our politics weighing on
this market will we have a government
shutdown on Friday or not no one knows
let's go to the UK and brexit how are
they going to leave the European Union
Theresa May survived a no-confidence
vote last week but she still feels like
she's got one foot on ice and another on
a banana peel
we've got microns troubles in France and
we've got this trade skirmish all of
that uncertainty is weighing on this
market I read one Wall Street analyst
said if Santa Claus doesn't show up soon
US stocks are gonna end up in negative
territory for the year okay but let's
put that in perspective it's been a
decade since we've had a down year ten
years now the last town year 2008 that
was a doozy but this is not normal that
the market goes up for 10 years so we
should know trees do not grow to the sky
I've said that before down markets do
happen but the upward trajectory of the
stock market is up is this your way of
saying don't freak out we've gotten used
to no volatility yeah it has been
unusually calm over the last decade I
know it doesn't feel like that but it
really has this is more normal we're
just not used to and we started the show
with a potential government shutdown
what impact would that have on the stock
market I don't think it would be a good
thing it just again gets to the
dysfunction in our politics I think
everyone knows at some point
the government is going to function that
we're not going to you know go for any
extended period of time without the
government functioning we've had this
happened before and so that's a good
thing but I think at the end of the day
it just shows that these are
self-inflicted wounds and it just shows
that anything can happen this is not
rational a government shutdown is not
rational and as you said many headwinds
facing the market and the economy as
well but a lot of good news out there
the US economy is strong unemployment
still super low things have been going
well the fundamentals look good even if
the growth is starting to slow around
the world our blood pressure has just
gone down a little bit here on thank you
melody
we appreciate it